نعطيهم الاشاش
المعقم لكي يقوم بالعرض عليه لتخفيف الالم
الذي يشعر
[موسيقى]
به تم اجراء عده عمليات منها عمليات
قيصريه لسيدات بدون ب على الاطلاق وهذا
كان شيء مؤلم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جدا كان بنا عملنا لحاله عمليه م ملته بكل
بطنها وهي معرضه للخطر وهي بدها عينيه
مركزه ما لقيناش مكان نحطها في عينيه
مركزه يعني اللي قدرنا نوفرها هي غرفه
صغيره لحالها عشان ما تعديش ناس ثانيه
وممكن في اي لحظه
[موسيقى]
نفقدها يا طمي
عليوم حوام ان شاء الله ان شاء الله خير
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
خير الحالات اللي بتيجي مصوبه كلها هي
تفيم فصا في المشيمه احنا بنروح على ال
بنروح على الحالات اللي في الجراحه بعد
الاصابات من القصف بنلاقي البيبيهات ميتا
بطنها بنلاقي الام ميتا والبيبي باخر
انفاسه ممكن يلحق وممكن ما
[موسيقى]
يلحقش الستات دخلت في نزيف بعد الولاده و
ما عرفناش اعامل معاها لان احش قاعدين في
مبنى الجراحه نتعامل معها رفعنا رحم لستات
وهي ممكن تتعامل معاهم لكن لعدم توفر الدم
خذنا القرار في رفع الرحم لانه نقدرش ناخذ
فرصه اطول لان ممكن فرد
[موسيقى]
العيانه